في التطورات العسكريه ايضا قالت قياده
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه انها دمرت مجمعا
للصواريخ الروسيه من نوع اس 400 بالقرب من
قريه
بشبه جزيره القرد وبث جهاز المخابرات صورا
قال انها لتفجير المنشاه التي تحوي
منظومات للصواريخ الروسيه المضاده
للطائرات طويله ومتوسطه المدى والفرق التي
تعمل على تشغيلها ووصف بيان المخابرات
تفجير مجمع الصواريخ بانه ضربه موجعه
للقوات الروسيه
وفي قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تتقدم ميدانيا رغم الظروف التي
تواجهها وفي انفتاح وفي افتتاح اعمال منصه
القرن بالعاصمه الاوكرانيه اكد زيلينسكي
ان بلاده ستتمكن من تحرير شبه جزيره القرم
والمناطق الاوكرانيه الاخرى المحتله حسب
تعبيره وانشات اوكرانيا منصه القرم عام
وتعقد اجتماعا دوريا في الثالث والعشرين
من اغسطس اب كل عام لتدوين قضيه القرن
التي تسيطر عليها روسيا منذ عام 2014
معنا من لندن مدير مؤسسه ايستوك للدراسات
الامنيه والشؤون الاوروبيه نيل برنت سيد
النيل هذه المرحله من الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا توصف بانها بامتياز مرحله
المسيرات حتى الان المعطيات في مصلحه منبع
باعتقادك
الاخيره
هناك جديد فيها وهو قدره الاوكرانيين على
ضرب العمق
الروسي بما فيه وسط موسكو وهذه هجمات ليست
كبيره ولكنها رغم ذلك اظهرت
للروس بان الكرملين ليس بتلك القوه وانه
سيكون هناك كلفه على روسيا لهذه الحرب
وليس الامر مرتبطا بالعاب وتسليه تعرض على
شاشات التلفاز
كيف تعقد قمه القرم اليوم والرئيس
زيلينسكي يتكلم عنه ويتحدث عن استعاده شبه
جزيره القرم وتنفذ المخابرات الاوكرانيه
عمليه نوعيه فيما تقول بانها منشاه
لصواريخ اس 400 وانها ضربه موجعه
لروسيا ما قاله زيلينسكي هل يبدو واقعيا
لا اعتقد ان الامر مستحيل
احد الامور التي يمكن للاوكرانيين فعلها
هو خلق الزعر هائل بين السكان الروس في
القرم اذا اذا ما استطاعوا ان يقوموا بقطع
اتصالات الجسر
والارتباط
الارضي فمن على الارجح سوف نرى
عددا كبيرا من المدنيين الروسي فيرون من
القرن وهذا سيكون له اثر نفساني عظيم على
روسيا
وسوف يكون ايضا تطورا سلبيا للكرملين من
الناحيه السياسيه
موسكو وجهت انذارا لحلفاء كييف الغربيين
بانهم يدعمونها في تقديم المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه وبالتالي ماذا عن هذا البعد
في الحسابات حسابات هذه الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
من الواضح انه كان هناك
تبادل كثيف في المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
بين
كييف وحلفائها الغربيين كما كان الحال
ايضا في تزويد الكيف بالسلاح القيود على
اوكرانيا
تتمثل في ان الاسلحه الغربيه لا يسمح لها
ان تستخدم على اراضي روسيه اذا فهذا الان
هو ما يتم نقاشه في هذا الصدد فيما يتعلق
بامكانيه استعاده شبه جزيره القرم من قبل
الجانب الاوكراني قلت للسيد بيرنيت بان
هذا امر ممكن
الا يدخل هذا في اطار الدعايه المبالغ
فيها شاهدنا اوكرانيا في الاشهر الماضي
تتكلم عن الهجوم المضاد حتى الان المعطيات
على الارض تبدو اكثر تعقيدا وبالتالي
عندما يكون الامر يتعلق بالشبه جزيره
القرم الا يعد هذا الامر شبه مستحيل حتى
الان في ظل هذه المعطيات
اعتقد انه صعب للغايه ولكنه ليس مستحيلا
لقد كان هناك توقعات عاليه جدا من الهجوم
الاوكرانيه المضاد ومن الطبيعي انه
سيستغرقه اسابيع او اشهر من حرب الاستنزاف
لكي يكون هناك تقدم ملحوظ نرى الان
[موسيقى]
المدفعيه الاوكرانيه والتي لها اثر عظيم
في الميدان بينما الجانبان
يتعاملاندا والدعايه السياسيه
وبالتالي فانه من قبل الدعايه ان اوكرانيا
سوف تستعيد القرن حسب رايه شبه جزيره
القرم بالنسبه للجانب الروسي هي نقطه
استراتيجيه من الصعب جدا لروسيا ايا كانت
الحسابات ان تستغني عنها الروس تحدثوا في
الايام الماضيه على ان الحرب في
الاوكرانيه كانت منصه
ليثبتوا للعالم بان اسلحتهم جيده وفعاله
في مقابل الاسلحه الغربيه وبالتالي ايضا
سؤالي ما الذي يجعل امر ان يكون هناك
تغيير في شبه جزيره القرم امرا واردا
القرني او بالاحرى هناك امران هناك الجبهه
العسكريه هناك الجبهه النفسانيه او
السيكولوجيه اذا ما راى ما راينا فرارا
جماعيا من القرم
ولن تعود ارضا روسيه محتله واذا ما راينا
ايضا
تطورا كاملا لهذا الامر على شكل استعاده
عسكريه للقرن فهذا الامر ليس مستحيلا
وخاصه انه يمكن محاصرتها من البر والبحر
شكرا لكم لندن مدير مؤسسه لدراسات الامنيه
والشؤون الاوروبيه نايل شكرا جزيلا لك